Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie, happy Thanksgiving,
Kevin Feige was recently talking about the
state of comic book filmmaking Marvel versus
DC, so I wanted to make a video about that
but Marvel and DC characters literally fought
each other in the Amalgam universe, so I'll
explain that to, so here we go
This doesn't have to end in a fight Tony.
You just started a War!
It's time you learned what it means to be a man.
Stay down! If I wanted it you'd be dead already.
She with you?
I thought she was with you?
I could do this all day.
Underoos!
Hey everyone.
So let's start with the fun stuff first, open pitch battle between Marvel and  DC characters in the Amalgam universe if you
never heard of it.
It was a limited series in the mid-90s where
DC and Marvel wrote a story that was like
out of the main continuity where the characters
from the different companies learned of each
other's existence and then fought this battle
the losers universe would die off.
So like if the Marvel characters one Mortal
Kombat style DC's universe would be killed
off but it was out of continuity.
So is just a fun way to say this isn't really
happening in spoiler warning for the end of
that story.
I'll just wait a second or because while escape
for in the video like 30 seconds.
So what ends up happening is is it becomes
this situation whereby they combine the two
universes despite Marvel characters having
won the battle but there's like a big twist
whereby they allow the two universes to be
fused it becomes the Amalgam universe with
you know both Marvel and DC characters in
it, but the actual battles that they thought
were Aquaman versus name or, Elektra versus
Catwoman flash versus Quicksilver Robin versus
Jubilee silver surfer versus Green Lantern
Thor versus Captain Marvel Superman versus
the hold Spider-Man versus Superboy Batman
versus Captain America Wolverine versus Lobo
in store versus wonder woman.
So like when you see Superman holding Thor's
hammer and Captain America's shield going
on and on about how amazing it feels.
That's from the a Amalgam comics but as for
whether they would ever do that in the movies
I don't think there's ever a chance for that.
Maybe they might make an animated movie, but
that seems like a long shot, there's always
lots of jokes and references that Marvel makes
the DC characters and its titles DC does the
same thing with Marvel characters I think
is just gonna stay at that level for the time
being, but I told think it's possible they
could revisit this idea in some like alternate
form a media even if they can't do it in the
live-action films but the ongoing debate Marvel
versus DC has largely just been a comic book
thing you know thanks to the efforts of Stanley
and the people at DC in the past 40 to 50
years.
So as was the case then you know typically
the people of the top like Stanley like Kevin
Feige nowadays which as you know most of my
reason for making this video were really cool
with the competition, despite it being very
friendly like a football match.
You want your team to win, but that doesn't
mean that you hate the other team.
So maybe this is a surprise to you.
Maybe it's not a surprise but Kevin Feige
said that he is a fan of all superhero films
like all studios who are adapting from what
he says the comic book medium so that includes
like Fox that includes the Sony people but
obviously they board he made the arrangement
for Spider-Man, but you know Kevin Feige just
seems like a really cool dude who really loves
comic books and really loves to make movies
so there isn't like an ounce of hate inside
his heart for any of his suppose it competitors
certainly each comic book studio has its own
criticisms Marvel and DC are just like the
two big ones, just because the IP that they
control no fox X-Men universe is still really
big to but comparatively there's fewer movies
that they could make, but even though they
share some of the same issues as DC's films.
Criticisms are actually very very different
like when you look back at the old Marvel
films a lot of them almost look like TV shows,
just because the way they film them, they've
largely try to change that.
But they had phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 they
had a lot of movies to kind of tweak the way
they make their films look so because DC chose
to start its film universe the DCEU with Zack
Snyder and probably his biggest skill is his
visual style like the DC movies that we've
seen so far look amazing, but the problem
is is there's like a billion different things
that make a really good film.
So even if it looks amazing that doesn't necessarily
guarantee that it's going to be an amazing
experience and really I think that's the most
important thing is like what you feel like
when the movies over and I think in each case
like Marvel even like the X-Men films and
DC films are all really fun to watch.
But the problem is is that there are certain
films in each of their libraries the just
like art really fun to rewatch again and again,
so really the mark of a really good comic
book film is something that you can rewatch
like a billion times that when I was a little
kid I was able to rewatch the Star Wars films
over and over because they were pretty good
films with a pretty good story and they visually
looked really interesting at least for the
time.
I mean obviously film has evolved a lot since
the original Star Wars movies have been made
2016 in particular is been a really hard year
for comic book films just because of what's
going on in the world what's happening in
the United States.
So get people just get angrier and angrier.
So you look to films like these to make you
feel better about existence and light so when
you see a film with a really dark tone that
doesn't necessarily help us with a the greatest
crimes against comic book films this year
were mostly crimes of tone not so much of
story because there are always story problems
and comic book films Captain America Civil
War very fun film to watch with a very hopeful
twist at the end but it also has all kinds
a story problems along the way so you look
at a film like Deadpool, the kind of terms
that on its head, which is why think it did
so well because it had just the right tone
for the right story for the right character
at the right time and I think the answer to
that like the tone problem of this year and
you know where Deadpool got right in 2016.
Spider-Man Homecoming will get it right in
2017 along with Justice league, we can talk
about what happened to Superman at the end
a Batman v Superman, and I think most of us
have a pretty good idea of what can happen
with his arc during Justice league, but you
maybe some people haven't read the comics.
They don't know the death of Superman arc
let's just say there's gonna be some really
exciting stuff happening in Justice league
and don't forget, there is a Star Wars movie
happening at the end of the year.
There's a very small Star Wars episode eight
movie.
Very quiet in the production, so a lot of
the pessimism that you see in the fandom now
will largely be gone by the time that gets
here, just because of the things that are
coming in 2017 in the fact that the studios
have seen like the way people reacted to all
the movies that come out this year is that
okay work and listened we understand you really
liked these characters but you're not super
happy with the way they treated them in these
movies so Marvel versus DC at the box office
Marvel crush that this year DC crusted this
year to despite what people thought about
each of their films like they were people
that hated the Marvel films this year it will
people that hated the DC films this year but
they still make billions of dollars all around.
That is because one they have really good
marketing machines so regardless of the quality
of films that will always be people that will
show up for Ben Affleck Henry Cavill Robert
Downey Jr, but the reason why you see all
kinds of movies make crazy money even if they're
not the greatest films ever is because people
love those characters so will show up for
their movies, which is that they'll be a lot
of complaining after the fact like I can't
believe that movie was so terrible but they'll
still go see the next movie with that character
even if the previous movie wasn't that great.
So the city is pick up on that the like okay
people of Batman people love Captain America.
We understand you're not super satisfied with
the last movie we made will do better next
time so they go back to the kitchen they bring
the meal out they try to make it better.
This actually played out pretty early on with
Marvel's films.
If you member the Incredible Hulk not the
greatest film ever.
But I think it's been long enough that people
largely give Marvel a pass just because there
been so many Marvel films since then they've
had enough time to hit their stride they found
the right actors like they started to land
some really big a list talent like Cate Blanchett
is in a Thor movie that just seems ridiculous
and exciting, but ridiculous that she would
sign on after seeing the first to Thor movies,
but DC has only just started like it took
him a long time to make Batman v Superman,
so that you know the problem with making films
is that it will take you a couple years.
So you're making this huge bed so you don't
get feedback till the movie drops they got
their feedback.
Now they can go back make a better film bring
it back it just that Marvel has been through
that grinder.
So many more times than DC has so far the
DC will get there.
Geoff John's is the new Kevin Feige there's
a comic book guy up at the top of his neck,
let them drag the characters through the mud,
though it is gonna take a little while to
make these movies so you know that's why I
think a lot of people were disappointed this
year because it's like hey you know we want
a better movie in the like okay will make
a better movie but it just takes a couple
years to get there.
Mark my words and like the next five years
what you're gonna see is Josie like the slate
of Geoff John's pioneer DC films in the be
a much more equal consensus from Marvel quality
and DC quality.
So I think of the Marvel films that people
will be really satisfied with in the next
couple years will be Spider-Man Homecoming
Thor Ragnarok Black Panther in both infinity
war films on the DC site I think those films
of people will be most happy about.
After leaving the movie theater will be Justice
league the flash Aqua man you can't decant
not like Jason Momoa is like one of the best
actors that they've ever landed in the man
of steel SQL Superman films more than anything
that your DC's opportunity to make heartwarming
films that are really exciting, you could
rewatch a billion times and you guys can let
me know in the comments like which Marvel
and which DC films.
Do you think will be the most re-watched in
the next five years there will be like the
flash film will be the Justice league film
infinity war there like certain films there
just so much more fun to watch from Marvel
and DC and have already re-watched most of
the Marvel films so many times that it started
to be like a song that you can't get out of
your head.
So attend appreciate the smaller ones like
ant Man Doctor strange things that do really
weird different things which is why am super
excited about Thor Ragnarok, so it's a little
bit easier to rewatch stuff you haven't already
seen a billion times which is why Kevin Feige
said that they're trying to do so many different
things and phase 3 and phase 4 that they've
never done before, which is the same for the
other studios.
So like Kevin Feige said he's really excited
about the films his competitors are making
he's really excited about DC films.
I think it's the same thing from Geoff John's
and the DC people know most of the comic book
guys that you run into are actually really
cool dudes there are like a few Mr. Burns
type people up at the top it all the studios,
but largely like they're getting pushed out
the door.
So like Kevin Feige was able to take Marvel
studios off on their own so that.
Not to worry too much about that the DC people
may Geoff John's one of the new gods of their
film universe the just so much exciting stuff
happening it's gonna be dropping next year
literally next year like you not have to wait
that long, and another is a lot of rumors
about trailers for like Justice League Spider-Man
dropping in the next couple weeks, but be
sure to subscribe to get everything I will
be doing a Spider-Man Homecoming Carnage video
later tonight so that will post in a couple
hours but if there are any comic book bonus
videos that you guys want me to do or movie
bonus videos this weekend.
Just let me know in the comments while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
to watch the funny Spider-Man Tom Holland
video where he gets that special Batman surprise
and you can click here to watch the latest
Arrow Flash big 4 night crossover Trailer
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!